[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 Marta Moya está en el estudio
para hablar Marta de el medio cómo somos
kaia prafta afina el kremming que recoge
no una entrevista al jefe de
inteligencia ruso en la que dice que
Polonia estaría dispuesto a impulsar
referendos de anexión para tomarse
varias regiones del Oeste de Ucrania
Rosa qué podemos ampliar en este Marta
Perdóname qué podemos ampliar en ese
artículo Buenos días Raúl Pues sí nos
referimos a ser gaynar que es el jefe de
la inteligencia exterior rusa en la que
da una entrevista a la agencia de
noticias
riano bosti y dice que Varsovia estaría
intentando organizar referendos para
varias regiones que pertenecieron al
Estado polaco entre la primera y la
Segunda Guerra Mundial esta anexión
sería de los territorios occidentales de
Ucrania de elviz ivano Franz Kid y la
mayor parte de la región
según informes del presidente André duda
supuestamente Pues revisados por la
agencia de inteligencia rusa duda habría
ordenado a las autoridades competentes
polacas que justificaran de inmediato
esta anexión de los territorios y esta
premura estaría sobre la mesa por unas
posibles negociaciones con los
principales aliados de La otan junto a
Rusia a espaldas de Ucrania y Polonia de
Cara a este invierno no Además dice que
según Polonia estaría buscando una
justificación para compensar todo el
apoyo militar que ha ofrecido a Ucrania
además de la acogida de millones de
refugiados y la caída de misiles en
suelo polacoque dejaron dos muertos
narizkin este jefe de la inteligencia
rusa Eso sí sostiene que ha amenazado
con Apolonia Con que no se anexione
estos territorios porque la historia
está llena de amargos ejemplos de
enfrentamientos nacionalistas entre
ucranianos y polacos seguimos con la
prensa rusa Marta ahora vamos a comentar
un artículo del medio independiente del
Moscú Times que analiza los entresijos
del encuentro de la semana pasada entre
Putin y las madres los soldados que
están en el frente de esta guerra sí
Raúl hace una especie de explainer del
encuentro que se dio la semana pasada
entre Vladimir Putin y algunas de las
madres de los soldados que están
sirviendo en Ucrania ante esto Pues
justificado con el día de la madre en
Rusia que fue la semana pasada no antes
de que terminara este encuentro los
periodistas que estaban cubriendo el
evento se dieron cuenta de que las 17
mujeres que participaron en esta reunión
pues serán afines al gobierno de
Vladimir Putin o incluso al partido
Rusia unida que es el partido de
gobierno no por ejemplo había mujeres
con vínculos con el idr chileno cadirov
o incluso una productora que Define que
hace películas pro gubernamentales y
ultraconservadoras el Moss you Times
analiza un poco estos entresijos dice
citando a Fuentes del kreming
exfuncionarios del gobierno ruso que a
Putin no le gusta encontrarse con gente
que le pueda hacer sombra y que pueda
hacerle preguntas incómodas no por tanto
el kremlin seleccionó a estas mujeres e
incluso les hizo hacer un ensayo previo
al encuentro público no el kremlin Busca
además dar una imagen de que putins se
solidariza con estas madres y además
delega las consecuencias de la mala
estrategia rusa al Ministerio de defensa
y no en su persona y vamos con más a
prensa rusa independiente porque hoy el
periódico medusa recojo en su portada un
reporte sobre el estado de salud de una
Popular opositor en velarus Sí hablamos
de María calesnicaba que se convirtió en
una de las figuras opositoras más
reconocidas tras las protestas anti
Alexander rukasengo que tuvieron lugar
en el marco de las elecciones de agosto
de 2020 esta opositora pues intentó huir
a Ucrania también la intentaron deportar
rompió su pasaporte y al final fue
condenada a años de prisión acusado de
extremismo y de intentar tomarse el
poder de manera ilegal ahora mismo esta
mujer está en cuidados intensivos Y tuvo
que ser trasladada del centro
hospitalario o sea de la cárcel al
centro hospitalario para someterse a una
cirugía pero según retrata medusa no se
sabe exactamente qué le pasa a esta
opositora porque el equipo médico no ha
dado un diagnóstico sobre su estado de
salud que además también se ha impedido
a la familia ver a su familiar que está
ahora mismo en el hospital y que a su
abogado se le ha también negado
visitarla en prisión durante las últimas
dos semanas cambiamos ahora el tema y
nos vamos hasta Ucrania porque el medio
Kid post ha publicado un curioso
artículo sobre Siete cosas que uno puede
hacer en la capital ucraniana en medio
de esta guerra sí Raúl dice pues que a
pesar de que los extranjeros puedan
tener una imagen distorsionada de lo que
pasa en la capital ucraniana pues la
vida sigue para millones de personas no
destaca siete cosas que se pueden hacer
a día de hoy en kiev por ejemplo ir a un
McDonald's dice que los misiles no
sobrevuelan las 24 horas sobre la
capital y qué mejor para restaurar ese
sistema nervioso que tomarse una jugosa
hamburguesa segunda cosa ir al cine los
estrenos cumplen con las previsiones de
la cartelera Aunque si en ese momento
suben a las sirenas antiaéreas la gente
tiene que evacuar el cine pero si
guardan el ticket pueden reprogramar su
visita de manera totalmente gratuita
otra cosa ir de compras a pesar de todas
las vicisitudes los centros comerciales
en kiev siguen llenos y la gente no se
rehúsa a decorar sus casas con motivos
navideños la cuarta cosa es ir al
restaurante sobre todo pues aunque
muchos restaurantes han tenido que
cerrar por la pandemia y luego la guerra
todavía se puede visitar los
restaurantes Aunque a menudo a la luz de
las velas el quinta la quinta cosa que
se puede hacer es ir a torneos
infantiles o a fiestas de cumpleaños
sostiene el post que los niños a veces
se reúnen en búnkeres para jugar a
videojuegos e incluso tomar ha la sexta
cosa es que se puede ir a la oficina Eso
sí a las que no están dañadas por los
misiles rusos y la séptimo cosa es que a
pesar de las sirenas antiaéreas se puede
seguir escuchando música callejera en